tonight's ccsd board meeting discussing
the news that two local high schools are
set to get a huge amount of money for
security upgrades sasha loftis is at
tonight's meeting she has more on what
this will be used for and why some say
other campuses should be
considered denise and brian tonight's
meeting started about an hour ago and
the big talker tonight is the huge
amount of money two high schools are
getting for security upgrades
el dorado high school is receiving more
than 26 million while clark high school
is getting nearly 100 thousand documents
show both schools will get more cameras
and a secure entry point in the front of
campus along with fencing you'll
remember a number of violent situations
were reported at various ccsd schools
last school year eldorado being one of
them when a student allegedly attacked
and sexually assaulted a teacher but
some are wondering if any other schools
across the district will get any
security funding like this the district
released a statement saying needs and
costs vary from school to school of
course this meeting is set to continue a
while longer we'll of course be here all
night long stay with 8 news now for the
very latest we will have a live update
coming up at 11 o'clock sasha loftis
live local now